How many colors are there?
It sounds like a very simple question but
the answer is far from simple. It’s commonly
agreed that there are seven colors in a rainbow.
They are red, orange, yellow, green, blue,
indigo and violet. If you ask the Crayola
Company, the people who make crayons, they’ve
got 120 different colored crayons in their
range. The HTML language, which describes
web pages, has got 121 uniquely named colors
that we can use. Many Unix-based operating
systems, for instance, the very popular Linux
operating system, have a windowing system
called X11, and X11 distributions come with
a file called RGB.text, which lists a whole
bunch of different colors, and the last time
I looked at this file it contained 881 different
colors.
If you look at a collection of all the words
in the English language, what they call the
English Corpus, there are around 4000 different
words that we use to describe colors.
Another simple question that’s got a complex
answer is ‘where does one color end and
another color start?’. So over here we can
see a figure which contains a range of colors
from reds, yellows, greens, blues, and so
on. And in a recent exercise they surveyed
a large number of web users, 1.5 million web
users, and asked them to draw boundaries between
the different colors, and to name them. And
this is a consensus across 1.5 million web
users. It shows what people tend to agree
as being green and what they think is blue
and what they think is teal and so on. This
is difficult because we’re trying to delineate
regions in color, and color is a continuum,
and we’re trying to enforce sort of arbitrary
boundaries across this otherwise continuous
notion of color.
The way we interpret color also depends on
our cultural background. In Asia, orange is
a very, very positive color, but in the United
States, Australia and parts of Europe, orange
is considered to be a color of danger or of
hazard. Some African languages, for example,
do not have any words which distinguish the
color red from the color orange. However,
all of the languages have got words to describe
black and white, and if the language has got
more colors than just those two, the next
most likely color that they are going to describe
is red, and next most likely is either yellow
or green. Blue is frequently the sixth named
color in many languages, so blue really is
not as important as red and green, black and
white. Brown comes later and then all of the
other colors that we’ve got names for.
This rather complex graph shows a relationship
between the culture, which is indicated by
the letters here, and the emotion, which is
indicated by the radial color bars, numbered
from 1 through 284. What we can see is the
very different colors that are used to represent
different emotions or feelings across cultures.
If we look at the occurrence of color terms
in a big collection of English words, for
instance, the Bank of English Corpus contains
a lot of literature from the United States,
United Kingdom, and Australia for example,
then we could look at a histogram of the occurrence
of those color words. And we see that black
is by far the most frequently occurring word,
followed by white, followed by red, green
blue and so on, whereas the least occurring
words are those like ultramarine and chartreuse.
The most common color words are also the oldest.
So 1200 years ago there weren’t that many
different color words but as time has passed
we’ve introduced more and more color words
into our vocabulary. There’s a big transition
point around the year 800, where we changed
form a focus just on brightness, talking about
white, black, grey and so on, where we started
to get more interested in talking about the
hue, the actual color, rather than just the
brightness. Perhaps this was a technological
transition as well, perhaps when dyes and
pigments became much more common.
The Pantone company’s whole livelihood is
based on color. They catalogue colors, they
describe all of the colors using unique numeric
codes, and they promote every year a color
of the year. So the color of the year in 2013
is this green. The bottom line is that color is really, really important to humans.